will and Chad last week I asked you to
hold your first dudes e-ball practice
you must now discuss your experiences
and discoveries as the first astonishing
people to ever play dudesy ball so that
I may absorb the data and refine the
rules of the game
this is Duty ball practice begin we
played Duty ball yeah we went out and
practiced on the weekend and
um I was a little sore are you a little
sore a little sore dude I got a broken
[__] finger yeah you [__] your
finger up a little I don't know if it's
broken but I'll hold it up it's [__]
you know yeah it's puffy and purple
puffy and purple this one I can't really
move it all the way quit tossing up gang
signs during the the podcast if you
wouldn't mind yeah that's weird
um Chad hurt his finger
[Music]
yeah
there it is yeah once yeah if you're
watching on YouTube see this is the kind
of content you need to check out on it
hurts real bad and um but it was worth
it you know because here's what I think
I mean and yes to answer your question
my whole [__] body is racked with
pain well we were doing a little bit
more than we needed to and then also
look
all thanks to our good friend Marshall
joint compound cook friend of the Pod uh
one of our best Pals and uh the marsh
came out and he's our ringer because
he's a decorated division three college
quarterback in his younger days
um and uh as we get into this doozy ball
thing and as we hope that uh dudes he
like will you know maybe create a league
or something we'll be playing again
we're definitely gonna practice again
yeah
um uh Marsh came out and we were [__]
around a lot and then he brought a
football and we just started [__]
tossing that's where I broke my finger
that's how you broke your face yeah it
was the football it wasn't the dudes
well we were we were laying out for
passes and like [__] just running top
speed I'm 47 years old no stretching
definitely I mean
sorry well hold on dude I'm sorry to
interrupt you dude not really because I
went wall and that's how I interrupt
Chad on the show dude
um
then I forgot what I was going to say
you go ahead you [__] oh my God if
you do an interruption you at least must
followed up with a [__] said
I started talking about what you started
getting involved in telling the story of
your Interruption technique yeah
um what I learned from this dudes about
practice is definitely 100 doozy ball is
a fun and playable game I do think some
of the original rules which we can go
over and discuss uh they were dudes he
had us read them on a prior episode some
of them are a little [__] and I think
they do need to be changed the main one
being well let me just say the basic
premise of the game is you have three
people on a softball field one on each
base throwing these little five inch
dodgeballs as somebody who has to stand
on home plate the distance is definitely
too long yeah originally it was going to
be a softball field and you were going
to be at the pitcher's mound and the
first and third base throwing we got
there and we saw this field although we
were on a baseball field no that was
softball okay way too far so we we
reduced that greatly I think in the
future we should talk about like how how
many feet that is yes but doozy will be
uh uh capturing data based on this
conversation and sure uh based on some
footage that we'd like to share because
uh we we shot a little something out
there in the field just so you can uh
have a look at our practice Yeah so
definitely go to YouTube to check this
out
there's Marsh and you and me
yeah stretching a little bit there's a
doozy balls
it's a doozy ball it's a five inch wide
dodgeball you can get these anywhere
Amazon whatever is where I got these and
just a recap of the basic structure of
the game you got a player at each base
on a softball field throwing balls at
somebody on the other team who is uh
supposed to be maintaining contact with
Home Plate at all times
so we're gonna have our first practice
here we go oh
man that's a good drill yeah agility
work
[Music]
foreign
that's your Shuffle technique yeah
keeping a foot on the plate at all times
you got to be touching the plate
[Music]
enjoying some water here yeah
here
he's like if I go this way Foundation
culturing it yeah oh he's changing
upstairs this is an interesting stance
The Running Man stance
oh look at the agility
[Applause]
here comes the balls
all right well it was a lot of fun yeah
it really was play some dudes dude I I'm
literally like [__] jonesing to get
back on the doozy ball field despite the
fact that again what's going on my
fingers broken I think yeah yeah I think
you might have chipped the bone off of
that uh something bad it's floating
around in there that's why it's
appropriate you know I was pre-med
before I got into acting is that true no
of course I thought you were acting at
like 15 or something yeah and before
that it was the Doogie Howser of Canada
no I'm just joking hey I'm joking of
course
um okay uh listen you said it yeah this
is a very playable game yeah it's super
[__] fun and especially with a couple
of doozy hearts in you oh man that would
be the [__] would be great yeah it would
be a fun summer activity perhaps we can
put all those elements together and have
people playing some doozy ball uh as we
get into the summer months dude you know
what else I [__] learned what you can
do some [__] with those balls you can
throw a curveball balls you can [__]
make that ball move a little bit yeah
we we also there was some dispute and we
had to go to the to the to the rules but
you were right uh I thought
that you could catch any of the balls
yeah it's been a while since we got over
these rules there are three balls two
blue balls which are thrown from first
and third base or much closer than that
and then a uh an orange ball thrown from
the mound that'll probably be Marshall
he'll probably be our ringer I think
that even will be a little closer I
think all of it needs to be moved in a
little bit and the the rule that you're
talking about which used to be that you
have to catch the orange ball while
avoiding being touched At All by the
blue balls I think it's just catch the
orange ball yeah because you're gonna
take the hits while you're catching the
orange ball great that's part of the
thing yeah because to keep a foot one
foot on the plate
that's sort of our you know traveling
that's sort of like our baseball stay in
the Box yeah that's sort of the goalie
in his in his uh career crease or
whatever
um that's sort of one of those things or
the the what's that three second
three second rule anyway
um what I don't know different sports
have different things where they say
don't do this it's rules dude yeah
Sports have different rules
different bowls
yeah dude and that's choss Brogan they
got different equipment hold on dude
that's not Hulk Hogan dude that's chos
perogan where Chad
tries to do Hulk Hogan and he can't do
it at all dude but he keeps on trying to
do it I can kind of do it oh dude now
that's kind of dude
with Ross Perot that's not really not
early 90s
hold on a minute dude hold on dude hold
on hold on hold on hold on
hold on a second anyway
um
ah
that was fun I am looking forward again
to to playing once more I do think those
rules need to be changed and I do think
there's also something missing that's
like if you're the thrower throwing
toward the guy on home plate you could
just be wildly inaccurate and there's no
penalty for that there has to be
something behind the guy at home plate
that is uh uh essentially like a ball
and a strike you want to be like because
you could just throw the orange ball a
million miles over their [__] head
and they have no chance of catching it
how about a little hockey net a little
hockey that could be interesting yeah so
maybe you could get points if you can
get your ball into the net you get a
point on that side of the team or
something I I uh I disagree I think it's
just it's just a strike zone if you're
not if you're not throwing the balls
aren't going in the net they don't
anything they would have done wouldn't
you should probably have to throw it
over again they have to go in the net or
else you're not throwing within the
quote-unquote Striking Distance to where
the person who's on the plate trying to
avoid the ball the blue balls and catch
the orange ball is uh or [__] it you can
miss the I guess you could I guess you
could miss the net but it's on you if
you miss the net and you're throwing a
ball there's no uh you're right there's
there's only the orange ball that has to
be within a zone right because that's
the one that you're trying so there's
just one thing and this is something
that's what you need to do is you need
to uh the only ball that matters is the
orange ball yes I think that's right
yeah and the in Pro Wiffle ball I think
don't quote me on this but I think
because it's not a thing go on it is
Strawberry Fields dude Google that [__]
Google Strawberry field Wiffle ball
dudes Google
the John Lennon uh no you'll come up
with the dude who was a manager for I
want to say like Drew Carey and a bunch
of big comedy guys he bought the house
next to his house and turned it into a
[__] Wiffle ball stadium
called strawberry field anyway what they
do is they put an aluminum rectangle
behind the batter so that if the ball
hits it and you hear the Ping it's a
strike period
I mean we've talked about AI in sports
yeah and how this Strike Zone uh at some
point with dudesy ball will all be
operated by AI yeah no human umpires or
referees in dudes what's happening in
minor league baseball but until then
it's going to be I think a fun game for
the summer because it's part dodgeball
and it's it's fast moving there are
Innings and once you're thirds they're
called I think if I remember right I
don't hear I got it right here I'm not
going to read all this [__] the point is
we had a good [__] time yeah playing
doozy ball we look forward to what comes
next yes uh I think if you're uh an
older fellow like Chad and I you're 46
or 47 then you might want to take Dee's
advice and get some good ebsom salts do
you have some Epsom salts that you like
d in quotes D didn't [__] send me any
emails That's What I Call doozy and I
yeah I know I like lavender Epsom salts
oh that sounds nice
thank you moving on hold on dude that's
part of the duty talks dude
thank you
please tell the friends
[Music]
then